la cacería de disidentes continuó en
nicaragua el gobierno que lidera daniel
ortega arrestó otros cinco opositores
entre ellos a dora maría téllez y hugo
torres
este último fue amigo cercano de ortega
y este vídeo antes de su arresto hace 46
años arriesgue la vida para sacar de la
cárcel a daniel ortega y a otros
compañeros presos políticos pero así en
la vida así son las vueltas de la vida y
lo que una vez acogieron principios en
favor de la justicia en favor de la
libertad hoy lo han traicionado hoy son
sus principales enemigos de sus
principios desde inicios de junio han
sido arrestado cuatro opositores
precandidatos a la presidencia cristiana
chamorro juan sebastián chamorro arturo
cruz félix maradiaga y también el
empresario joxe agirre el ex canciller
josé palé y la activista opositora
violeta granera en paradero desconocido
los detenidos comparten una
característica ponen en peligro la
cuarta reelección de ortega como
presidente
daniel ortega gobierna nicaragua desde
2007 y se han parado en el argumento de
desestabilización política para
justificar la detención de los
opositores desde la esfera internacional
varias potencias y organizaciones han
pedido la liberación de los disidentes
amenazando con expulsar al país de la
oea en las calles la polarización es
evidente
y si se hagan unas elecciones libres
[Música]
debería pagar
el cargo que tenga a cinco meses de las
elecciones generales programadas para el
7 de noviembre de continuar estos restos
ortega y su partido serían los únicos en
participar